oh I'm sorry were you sleeping oh I can
clean that up with you on that's our
food sure can you get something cheese
though like Chinese not a fan pizza and
like this intolerant dude let's go out
tonight no I was just gonna standing
it's a work done so fine I guess I'll do
that too
so boring Oh burgers I don't eat red
meat Italian pasta doesn't agree with me
don't worry Mayra make sweeping
tapas I did I just let tacos last night
Indian food
[Music]
never
so she [ __ ] a guy while you're in the
room and the borrowed money is the final
straw dude stolen money man do you know
how poor I am very very poor okay
just do back finish I just I don't know
how much more I can take
Madison 15 guys do it dude she just like
she tries to go with me everywhere like
I had to leave while she was in the
bathroom just to get here oh why have
you tried talking to her I have tried
you're not there you're not in the
trenches with me do you know when the
last time I masturbated was four months
ago because she's always there I should
move out I don't know if it were me I
would just at least try talking to her
because dude moving is just like the
worst yeah it sucks I mean I guess I
guess I can try to talk to her and be
like an adult or whatever yeah give it a
shot
are you gonna go now don't wear your
high
[Music]
Tiffany we need to talk
yes June we do
I'm sorry to say but I'm moving out
[Music]